we have reason to believe the russian
forces are planning to and intend to
attack ukraine in the coming week
in the coming days
we believe that they will target
ukraine's capital kyiv
a city of 2.8 million innocent people
make no mistake
if russia pursues his plans it will be
responsible for a
catastrophic and needless war of choice
the united states and our allies are
prepared to defend every inch of nato
territory from any threat
to our collective security as well
we also will not send troops in to fight
in ukraine but we will continue to
support the ukrainian people
i'm now joined by dw stephen simons in
washington so joe biden seems convinced
that russia intends to invade do we know
how the us will respond if this conflict
turns hot
well uh
we have heard the most blunt comments so
far from the president i think with what
he just said you're absolutely right
but yeah the u.s is
says the president and say his
administration
prepared to
impose very very very severe sanctions
on russia so with nato allies with
european partners um they're working
actually and this is a quote from a
press conference conference
earlier today from the white house on
finalization of a severe final package
sanctions package and what is in this
package of sanctions it's of course
final
financial sanctions cutting
russia
out of the global market when it comes
to finances and
export controls meaning
that those sanctions are will be then
designed to not allow
russia to import anything uh from yeah
the european union and the united states
which would be says the white house a
strategic loss for
russia and
a calamity for president putin but
as you pointed out and what the
president pointed out there seems to be
a
waning waning confidence in the chance
of the mob diplomacy for uh ukraine
right now
all right so it does seem that there's a
lack of confidence in a diplomatic
solution but can there be any type of
diplomatic path out of this
crisis from the perspective of
washington
well i think that washington is still
hopeful americans are still hopeful
and the white house is still hopeful
there is a meeting scheduled for next
week between anthony blinken secretary
of state and
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
this is supposed to be happening at the
end of the week 24th of february
apparently but the president made really
uh
clear that if of course russia opts for
and vladimir putin opts for an invasion
into ukraine before this meeting happens
then
he is
potentially right with his assessment
that vladimir putin already made his
mind up on a invasion and on an attack
on ukraine and that the diplomacy has no
chance however
i think so far as of now everybody wants
to actively here in the united states
here in washington probably also in
european capitals give diplomacy still a
chance
that was stefan simons joining us from
washington thank you
the us says russia now has up to 190 000
troops positioned along its border with
ukraine tomorrow moscow plans military
drills of its nuclear arsenal a show of
strength that nato says is an attempt to
intimidate meanwhile moscow
moscow-backed separatists are evacuating
civilians eastern ukraine from eastern
ukraine rather to russia claim the
ukrainian army is planning an attack
[Music]
a warning to the people of donetsk that
it's time to go after the heads of the
separatist region's announced evacuation
plans
[Music]
president of ukraine vladimir zelinsky
will soon order the military to go on
the offensive to implement a plan to
invade the donetsk and luhansk people's
republic's territory
as of today february 18th a mass
centralized evacuation of the population
to the russian federation has been
organized
women children and the elderly are among
the first to be evacuated packed onto
buses bound for russia's neighboring
rostov region despite kiev again denying
any plans for military action
i reiterate that the military and
political leadership of ukraine doesn't
plan and are not conducting offensive
operations in ukraine's east the only
option for the occupation of the people
and territory that is acceptable to us
is the political and diplomatic one
according to kiev it's the
who have upped their attacks and it's
homes like these on their side of the
front line luhans that have been caught
in the firing line
locals say shelling has escalated lately
recently it has been quiet and then the
last two days every now and then they
shoot
every now and then they shoot
but donetsk too has seen increased
attacks a car bomb was detonated in the
heart of the city on friday evening the
reported owner the head of the
separatist region's military was not
inside at the time
the explosion comes just days after the
us and its allies warned about potential
false flag attacks by russia
for president putin the solution to the
current crisis lies with kiev
all kiev needs to do is sit down at the
negotiating table with representatives
of dunbas and agree on political
military economic and humanitarian
measures to end the conflict and the
sooner this happens the better
unfortunately right now we are seeing
the opposite an aggravation of the
situation in donbass
but with kiev and its allies still
warning of impending russian invasion
de-escalation appears a distant prospect
for more on the crisis in ukraine i'm
now joined by dw's nick connolly in kiev
so nick shelling has intensified in
recent days in the region and thousands
of people are being evacuated what's
your read of the situation
well things are definitely hotting up in
don bass in that eastern ukrainian
region that has seen war since 2014 but
where strange enough things had been a
bit quieter in recent months where we
had that huge russian troop build up
along ukraine's other borders um
very little in the way of fighting in
recent weeks up till basically the last
two days where we've seen even a
kindergarten on the ukrainian controlled
side
being shelled although no pupils wounded
images of people back in the bomb
shelters where they hadn't been for
years really a very clear escalation and
something people here in kiev the
government would say is a sign that
these separatists are basically at the
beck and call of the kremlin able to
dial up the pressure on ukraine when
russia is at least claiming to draw back
tanks and weaponry on other fronts um
but it really
weird situation different reports coming
in of explosions in luhansk today this
evening rather on gas pipelines images
of huge queues of people trying to buy
fuel to get out conflicting reports of
whether men in basically military age
between 18 and 55 are being allowed to
leave those separatist regions or
whether they're being uh encouraged or
indeed forced to stay and sign up for
some kind of military action so very
nervous and worrying situation that you
know people here didn't quite think he'd
imagine would go quite so fast
now the us government is concerned
russia could use the clashes in eastern
ukraine as a pretext to launch an
invasion is this also something that the
ukrainian government is concerned about
definitely and we've heard in recent
days not just from vladimir putin but
also from other russian officials uh the
word genocide being used kiev being
accused by russian
decision makers uh of committing
genocide against its own citizens in
eastern ukraine
of using weaponry of shelling uh those
separatist regions and of affecting um
civilians that's something that has
really come up and been really pushed by
the official russian line in recent days
reports of mass graves
of victims of the war from earlier in
the conflict being found and now legal
cases being made so the real feeling
here is that this is a cause
an attempt to find a cause for war to
basically have an excuse to
carry out a preventive strike against
ukraine um the line being that ukraine
is trying to take these regions back
with force and that russia would have to
come to those separatist aid to prevent
that happening so definitely a sense now
here in kiev that this is turning into a
hotter phase that after the kind of
diplomatic chewing and throwing of
recent weeks this is definitely now a
more dangerous situation
all right nick help us understand the
conflicting reports about the russian
troop buildup at the border with ukraine
moscow says it's pulling some of its
troop back but nato says they are
sending more troops to the region
well that's the thing at the beginning
of the week you had olaf schultz
germany's chancellor in moscow and he
basically seemed to have been able to
change the tone we heard from the
russians uh in the hours and days
following that visit that they were
going to reduce some of those troop
positionings along the ukraine frontier
take troops out of annex crimea but if
the satellite imagery that western
intelligence agency going on is to be
believed then they are basically just
redistributing those troops taking them
out of annex crimea and bringing them
back to positions their home garrisons
which are also very close to ukraine's
borders so nothing that really affects
ukraine's security and indeed new troops
have been spotted in different locations
so a sense really that this was
potentially just some maneuvering an
attempt to show some good will towards
olaf schultz but no real russian
commitment to de-escalating and indeed
it's difficult to see why they would
de-escalate but so far hasn't russia
hasn't got any of the things it was
demanding we haven't seen vladimir putin
either get a promise from nato to keep
ukraine out or to withdraw troops from
those eastern european nato members so a
sense that russia is going to keep on
escalating until it sees some uh return
on this pressure being applied to
ukraine in the west
all right that was dw's nick connelly
bringing us the latest from ukraine
thanks for joining us
you